so you take something like this and this
is entirely in algebraic terms but we
introduced a trig substitution because
there are identities under here that we
can take a bunch of does that make sense
so we turn algebra into tree because
sometimes having it intrigued for makes
it much easier to deal with so we get
away from audra go towards a tree and it
gives us a path through ok what this is
about is going in the exact opposite
direction right you've got something
it's in trig form if you can turn it
into algebra depending on the algebra
you end up do it then that might be
easier to do so it's not like trig
always better or algebra always better
like in different cases both of them are
quite awkward to deal with so you just
switch terms right I think I said this
to you before but a problem well phrased
is a problem half solved a problem or
phrase is a problem have stopped do
you've ever what I was talking about
those tangent you off about traffic last
week and how if you think about traffic
as an infrastructure problem you're like
let's fix it by adding motorways or
let's fix it by increasing public
transport right you end up making the
problem worse because thinking out
traffic as an infrastructure problem but
phrasing it in that way just makes it
more or less insoluble is everything you
trying to do mix upon worse if on the
other hand you phrase it as an economic
problem and saying okay how can we just
invented set of eyes this behavior or
that behavior you can actually get some
results and it's exactly the same thing
I mean I don't think it's true anywhere
than maths that's just the way you
phrase a question is the completely
different something is impossible or
something that's trivial okay so we're
gonna dig into T results which is like I
said going in the opposite direction and
we've done T results before so can we
remember what is our where Tootie
results begin yeah very good so we
actually looked at this not that long he
said okay well if you introduce this is
half angle result which is the other
name 40 results okay you can take
advantage of the double angle results to
get the expression for theta and sine
theta and cos they just kind of come
along for the ride so just using the
double enjoyable if I say
fig are right which is 10 of 2 feet or
two okay what will make double angle
results tell me I'm going to get to tea
or to tan of theta 1 2 which is
specialties on 1 minus t squared very
good okay so then where do we go from
there okay so move your sign now this is
opposite on adjacent rent opposite on
adjacent this is opposite on hypotenuse
so you're going to get the opposite part
and / and where does this 1 plus T
squared come from again try you can do
it for Pythagoras very very easy to go
okay that's sine theta lastly you can
say close theta what I'm going to do
that so again this is opposite over
adjacent so you take me adjacent part
hypotenuse is still the same so you get
this guy okay now this is good you can
see a problem like this which we looked
at last week do you remember we're
proving that weirdo looking blog result
and we simplified things down after
substitution and we got there and we're
like what do I do with this and we had
to play around a little bit we're gonna
do the same thing but this time we're
going to try it out with tier results
now I don't quite have enough to use
this over there yet what am I missing
this all of this stuff if I'm doing a
regular tricks of seizure right all this
stuff will help me to replace the
function okay but there is not just the
function to deal with in this integral I
can't just change the function i also
have to change the variable integration
the defeat are right how do i do that
yeah okay so I want some I want some d
theta on dt result here uh because you
can see here I've got all of these
different things you but I want to get
up d theta on the bottom okay now i'm
just going to pause for a second right
because here usually you know don't
write this stuff usually i'm going to
say something like this let you what was
the app what's the substation we chose
over you there Uniqua I'll site X equal
run on this one buy this photo
u equal to X so yeah okay and he like oh
that's the only thing i'm going to use
in here so that would become u square so
it's obvious what you're going to
differentiate in order to change these
like that's the only choice you have to
work from but when you look here you
have all these choices which one are you
going to differentiate and how I don't
want you to give me an answer yet I want
you to remember what am I trying to get
towards okay i am trying to change this
right and if i can sort of take
advantage of what i have here then
that's sort of like an advantage if I
over to buy the two up here that will
make things really nice and me if not
I'm just taken out by heart okay so I
want you to look at this you have three
options right have a play with them you
could differentiate any oh right which
one is going to give you the most
convenient resolve that will allow you
to change this very room intervention
you have a think you have a go on it if
you're ready answer that you can go
ahead and you can start integrating
black butt [ __ ] like i said here you
go all these choices right you have all
of these different kinds opens
articulations of the relationship
between theta and T any of which you
could use to find a deaf ear on dt of
some kind okay however out of four
options I've heard one of them jobs are
you as the most obvious right have a
look at these three have a look III you
could differentiate any of them however
neither theater lawtey are the subject
do you notice that so therefore if you
want to defeat on detail out of any of
these you're going to have one of two
choices you can either get this in terms
of inverse trig functions like for
example theta equals 10 inverse blah
blah blah blah right and then you can
differentiate that but that's going to
be terrible isn't it it's gonna be gross
right because imagine if you have to
differentiate this
okay the form that I'm used to seeing
here is this is such a terrible turn is
1 on 1 plus x squared yes that's the
dreary expecting except it's not X it's
this guy and then when chain rule comes
on for the ride you need the duty of
that as well yuck okay you maybe I'll
get something out of that it's going
pretty awful um what could you do to get
that DVD or TV without making theta the
subject so we have a tool here as
extension to students how can we work
with this without making thin to the
subject what's caught using chain rule
before you change the subject we could
use implicit differentiation right you
can just differentiate both sides with
respect to T just right off the bat this
is you're going to use chain rule here
this would become let's see seck square
theta d theta DT yeah and this will be
how will you differentiate that okay
that worth two but they're all kind of
awkward it's much better just to start
right at your first line and say hey
this guy t is already the subject she's
already the subject so i can
differentiate t that's the dependent
variable with respect to theta is that
make sense so i'm going to give this a
go dt on do clean up this is chain rule
what's the drill of the inside function
what's the derivative of the inside what
is the inside function it's Theodore to
right so the derivative of the inside is
aha what to do on the outside function
yeah very good okay now this is true but
it's not very helpful for us because if
I want to use this to get back into
their I need things in terms of UT's not
feeders right like I can just take the
reciprocal of this I can't tell your
typical by no other said well I want the
defeater on the bottom that's exactly
where I want it to be so cancel okay but
this is no use to me because in terms of
theories I'm trying to get away from
Peters are you tracking with me so far
so i need to change these this is what
i'm going to go back and use now we're
used to think of these in a right angle
triangle right the writer you trying
the wrong color that all of these
inhabit looks like this maybe if you
haven't already you want to draw it with
me here is the right angle triangle you
start with your feet up and there's the
opposite on adjacent that you got from
the first line and then you say by
Pythagoras there's your hypotenuse okay
so that looks good but what we often
forget is that the top load also implies
a triangle right it implies the triangle
not with angle theta but with engel
video too okay so let's draw I'm going
to draw it set up my feet onto its a
pick it up not that matters if I make
that feet are on to that angle there
what does this tell me that the sides of
the triangle what does it imply you're
getting opposite on a Jason right you're
still talking about 10 so that's T on
one do you agree does that look okay so
therefore again by Pythagoras I can get
the hypotenuse which is yeah thank you
square root of 14 c square the reason
that is useful to me is because there I
can use that to just evaluate this I can
evaluate that very very simply this is
equal to those of Recca a half times now
sex squared is 1 over close square one
Omar what is cause of federal to in this
triangle it's jason on hypotenuse right
it's one on the square root of 1 plus d
squared but in fact i don't what cause i
want cos squared so that's going to
eliminate the yet does that make sense
so what have I got here this is on the
denominator too so it flips one more
time and it says 1 plus T squared or to
that extent see what I did that that's
dte
on d theta ok so now I'm ready excellent
I can actually do some substitution here
i can multiply things through i'm going
to substitute this this year you see
that that's going to be my i'm on Hannie
the reciprocal of this because there's
SEC theta over there and this is what
I'm going to use to change the variable
of integration can you have it go at
that give that a shot see where voters